coming out today
floods in Nigeria kill more than 600
people with 340 000 hectares of land now
submerged
MPS say the mini budget won't go far
enough and call on the government to
travel its spending on Energy Efficiency
critical for our people and our planets
a new report finds 600 million people
are still in need of electricity and
clean cooking fuel we'll be discussing
whether climate change could be the
cause of billions of perhaps
mysteriously disappearing from Waters
around Alaska and
a pair of rare endangered pink river
dolphins are saved after getting trapped
in the Amazon rainforest
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis well at first this afternoon we
begin the show on the ongoing floods in
Nigeria where the combination of climate
change and conflict have resulted in a
dire situation for much of the country's
nearly 220 million population so unusual
rainfalls have contributed to the worst
flooding in Nigeria in more than a
decade and more than 600 people in
Nigeria have died this year as a result
of the heavy flooding so far 1.3 million
people have been displaced by the
disaster and over 340 000 hectares of
land has been affected worsening fears
of food supply problems while
authorities blame the disaster this year
on the release of excess water from
laddu Dam in neighboring Cameroon and on
unusual rainfall now the impact of the
floods on Farmland have worsened fears
of Food Supplies shortages already
strained by armed conflict ongoing in
Nigeria's North West well last week
Nigeria's president approved 12 000
metric tons of grain for the flood
victims and many of whom I've been left
with nothing
about everything
including our plants uh businesses who
are living like animals just like fish
in the water
most of our houses have them
have been you know are fair dinosaurs
mostly modern houses
and if you get there if you get to our
community
the water have gone above the zip level
situation of course and the pressures on
areas of Nigeria are set to intensify
with the minister of humanitarian
Affairs warning that five states are
still at risk of experiencing floods up
until the end of November
now MPS from across different political
parties are calling on the government to
treble the amount of money it's planning
to spend on Energy Efficiency now the
recent mini budget included spending an
extra 1 billion pounds on insulation for
low-income households to protect them
from the spiraling gas prices or Sky
Saudia Chaudhary uh joins me now hi
Saudia so what's the latest from the
government on this then
well the government has always insisted
that it remains committed to reaching
Net Zero carbon emissions by 2050 but
recently it has been criticized by
campaigners who say that it it appears
to be rowing back on those commitments
by policies like the lifting of the ban
on fracking and granting more oil and
gas exploration licenses in the North
Sea now the all-party Parliamentary
group is urging the government to show
more commitment by trebling the amount
it has pledged to spend on Energy
Efficiency so in the mini budget as you
just said the government had laid out
plans to spend an extra one billion
pounds on insulating low-income
households the appg wants to see that
number increase to three billion pounds
and this is part of its 10 point plan
for climate in the environment sort of
list of priorities that the government
should address in the next 12 months and
so what it wants is what it calls a
retrofit Revolution to address those
insulation concerns in homes it says
that will not only create jobs in the
country but will also permanently reduce
energy bills but it also wants to see
things like a cut in vat at public
charging points for electric vehicles
from 20 to 5 it wants to see more
funding for example for decarbonizing
agriculture so a list of things that the
appg has put forward as it urges the
government to spend more on addressing
Energy Efficiency and all of this comes
of course as the government is urging
all of us to do more to reduce the
amount of energy we use this winter so
things like switching off a light when
you leave the room or switching off
devices which would perhaps otherwise be
left on standby and you might remember
the boss of off gem last week talking
about more technical things that we can
all do like reducing the flow
temperature in our boilers which he said
perhaps won't reduce energy bills for us
individual customers but can help
address the energy supply issues that
the country faces this winter but the
government appears to think perhaps
there aren't those energy supply issues
going on yesterday the climate Minister
Graham Stewart said that the UK is in in
a pretty good position for supplies but
he failed to rule out energy rationing
this winter admitting that the risk of
blackouts is higher this year than in
previous years okay Saudia Chaudhary
thank you very much good to have you on
the show
time now for a look at some of the day's
other climate news for you and one third
of the world's 100 largest private firms
with revenues totaling nearly 1.2
trillion dollars don't have plans to
reduce carbon emissions that's compared
with over two-thirds of the largest 100
publicly listed companies Now new data
released by Net Zero tracker also found
that none of the top 10 private
companies have a net zero Target and
it's led to calls for enhanced
transparency and a drive for more action
in the private sector
now the Sunderland air show has been
canceled indefinitely as the council
looks to make the city carbon neutral
now the popular events which attracted
hundreds of thousands of Spectators was
last held in 2019 but hasn't gone ahead
since the pandemic well the councils say
their ambition is for the city to reach
carbon neutral status by 2040 and
therefore have no plans to run the air
show in the future
just stop oil protesters are still
blocking the M25 Dartford Crossing
demanding the government halts all new
oil and gas licenses and consents for
the Queen Elizabeth II Bridge which
links Kent to Essex was closed on Monday
after two people from the group climbed
to the top they say they'll remind
remain on top of the bridge until
they're brought down
now expanding access to clean energy
sources is crucial to The Climate crisis
but according to the new
multi-dimensional poverty index there
are still 600 million people who don't
have access to electricity and clean
cooking fuel now research by the United
Nations development program and the
Oxford poverty and human development
initiative found that improving access
is crucial for people and the planet
well earlier I spoke to Professor Sabina
akaya the director of the Oxford poverty
and human development initiative at
University of Oxford
the poor people that we look at are
facing a Nexus of different deprivations
that Collide that are bundled together
and a number of them are linked to
climate crisis it could be nutrition and
problems of rising food prices of food
insecurity lack uh lack of access and it
could also be as we've seen electricity
it could also be having good housing
materials and so in a sense there is a
need to address their situation with
providing the clean energy the climate
policies can do and in the sense also by
supporting them you are supporting
people living on the most vulnerable
parts of the planet and also therefore
having livelihoods that can change their
lives and also change the well-being of
the surrounding environments and it's
been a while we have you here cop27 it's
around the corner what would you like to
hear from this year's climate conference
in Egypt we are so conscious of the
climate crisis and simultaneously at the
present moment given the turbulence of
the Ukraine war of the difficulties of
the post-pandemic of the rising crisis
we are conscious of the burden of
poverty
so on the one hand we want Net Zero in
terms of the climate but we also want
Net Zero in terms of poverty and so
seeing both of these priorities as
synergistic as ethically important but
also reinforcing each other I think
would be a win-win
and finally just before we go two
endangered pink river dolphins have been
rescued in Bolivia's Amazon rainforest
after becoming trapped in still water
ponds a cut off from the Rio Grande now
the Dolphins I guess Rosy complexion is
due to blood vessels close to their skin
although some specimens are blue or even
white they're at risk though as
researchers have found that
deforestation has contributed to well a
sharp decline in their population rescue
groups are pushing to boost the species
and in the last 12 years have rescued
nearly 60 trapped dolphins
now you lucky things there's just over
two weeks to go until the United Nations
climate change conference in Egypt and
you can scan the QR code on the screen
now for your guide to cop 27 so do check
that out well that's all from us back to
you Sarah Jane